hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play mental okay
now this is supposedly a good and scary
game so let's get into it's been a while
since we played just a very simple indie
horror game that was meant only to scare
me so let's play it I very interested to
see what lies beyond the doors here and
hello
okay this was made on the FPS creator
engine which a lot of indie horror games
are do I have a flashlight
I do not okay so let's just carry on our
wayward way carry on my wayward son I
have to escape oh do I do I really is
that what I need to do right now escape
from where risky to use well this isn't
a good sign this is probably a bad sign
is that really dead nothing really dead
you ugly as hell you so ugly okay we got
skeletons in the side rooms a headless
guy over there door locked not locked
hello ah please leave that open because
I may need a quick escape
okay so we got Skellington this is some
mental hospital big burly dead guy weird
corpse got a bad feeling so I'm gonna
jump out of me hmm
what why what happened okay
alright strange ticking clock even
though there are no know what's in there
ooh I can't hit because other gay people
to go in there no I don't think I'm
supposed to go in there at all
wood water huh hello
it's in my ear those in my left ear it
felt like it was someone who's given me
a wet willy with a dagger
hello okay so this is this is nice I
like this I like this a lot
nope okay hi dad guy naked dead guy with
no nards someone's got no nards who's
got no no don't make fun of the dead
they may come back to haunt me okay
alright looks like we got a scientist
sing over in the other room okay are you
gonna do that every time I walk into a
room hon game go just make random noises
in my ear balls
stop it I don't know how they're doing
that but I got really good headphones
and it feels like they're inside my ears
okay Zak keys oh no I mean oh good I
mean keys but don't know because
something script it's gonna happen dude
oh I saw it I saw it there was one
locked door oh just get the log ha ha ha
really really really really okay alright
okay we're fine
we're fine we're fine why is this all
suddenly orderly this was not our label
for war what is that I see Diggs what
it's over there don't care don't care
don't care don't care gonna get out of
here dark Abdo floodlight I think I'm
being watched
oh oh come on light come back on you
can't trick me you can't fool me
I'm on full Abel come here yeah that's
right you stay on ah crap
hey what's in the bucket how can I put
the bucket in my head and block out all
the weird things keep people from
watching me equivalent to a tinfoil hat
okay let's go down the scary hallway
with brilliant king lights and weird
door at the end yeah let's do this
nope nope nope nope no I'm gonna nope
the hell out of here and so did I bond
we can I become cheap ego alright
nothing in here carrying on what you got
for me come on bring it on I'm ready for
you I'm ready for anything that you guys
just done to me what do we got well we
got lot eyelets these jail cells are
mental self no uh-uh no no hello no
there you I don't
uh-huh oh man when you guys play this
for yourself play with the volume turd
that was a delayed reaction on my part
what the hell is that what the hell's
our hat what the hell was that okay no
you stop that okay door locked door ooh
what I don't see anything it's too dark
I can't see anything
kissy-kissy there's nothing in here
there's nothing in here for me weird or
weird or the end of the hallway door
locked
okay no by me screw you and your face
and everything about your face you're so
ugly it's so ugly and stupid and your
face is dumb and scares little children
and I hate you
I did not expect that to actually open
okay okay okay
ah crap now this music
yip-yip-yip slip flopped
I saw something run over this way let's
scamper in this direction door locked
what a surprise I okay alright okay
the body is Rudy no jump-scare my body
was ready my body was so ready
hello quango tech village tech oh I
picked up a kid didn't even see a key
hooray hooray
hellooo you Lulu
good look man whoever did the sound in
this game is good because it felt like
that was scratching on the inside of my
skull Viki woopty doopty what is this I
scan I don't have on eyeball I don't
even have it won't handball I don't have
any balls anymore they fell off a long
time ago a boy playing this game huh huh
I feel like that don't do that to me
game you've been doing that to me got a
key
another key I like this game I like it
at all
I like it even a little bit oh wait do I
have an eyeball something anything
there's nothing in it rub wait do I have
a key I don't know can't tell it says I
have two keys in the bottom left but
have I use those I don't know oh I'm so
confused
I'm so confused oh here we go
Oh have a nice day sir madam whatever
the hell you may be I don't want any
part of it yeah oh he's dead oh good I
guess
give me your eyes in your hand give me
everything you got
I'll kill you ha ha ha ah stick about ah
yeah you just hang out there ah hi oh
why why sir madam I still don't know
what was over here nothing okay all
right I got a key think can have your I
know all right but press e to use did I
use it did I get it
lip my eye does not work I need
someone's eyeball whatever I got a
strange key card thing I don't know what
it goes to
but I mean deeds a backtrack editor
doors lock needs a handprint huh know
where I'm going
oh come on all right I'm a little
confused but I'll be okay okay I must
have missed something in this area did I
open every up the doors pretty sure I
did okay let's just take a breather
relax a bit it's calm down
calmly collectedly calm down all right
well this guy's gone because he
relocated outside he still won't give me
his hands or his eyes I won't hold that
against him uh okay all right okay okay
all right okay all right okay all right
huh at least I got a rest pipe from what
is happening because when I'm lost at
least at least say don't throw anything
more at me please tell you they use it
wait a minute what oh I didn't come in
here why not
when did I not come in here huh I didn't
realize that I missed that one
okay doors still locked ill don't have
proper eye balls what I probably need to
go is go back out here with oh my god oh
don't
I thought I was going to die I thought
that was it I was gonna die I don't know
okay thank you
oh I don't wanna look ahead I got an
eyeball hi okay [ __ ] off I wanna I don't
wanna I don't wanna
oh oh come on oh the hell all right
we're not gonna talk about what happened
sardar me
they get it I got it not go talk back
which way do I go cos god no no kill me
I'll kill me please invite Orvis I wanna
time ow ow ow ow ow my niblets my nards
ow ow ow ow ow ow ow
ow ow I didn't kill me but whatever
Chuck off I don't want any let's let me
go home let me go home let me go home
you say run I didn't know which way you
wanted me to run I want to go home why
what what next what now I see the exit
really really I need to return to my
wife and child I don't think you have
any I think those are all lies oh happy
end what
what why I don't know I'm tired I want
to go home I don't want to look at
anything ever again I'll gouge my
eyeballs out just paint the walls with
my own feces send me to a mental
hospital
this game has accomplished what it set
out to do maybe crazy bonkers I'm done
thank you all so much for watching don't
play this game and as always or maybe
not I will see you in the next video bye
Oh
Probert
what
Oh different